[موسيقى]
مصالحه مؤقته ام دائمه بعد العداء
التاريخي المصلحه تقتضي تقاربا في مواجهه
التهديدات النوويه لكوريا الشماليه لتوسيع
التحالف مع الولايات المتحده منذ 12 عاما
لم تعقد قمه ثنائيه بهذا المستوى بين رئيس
الوزراء الياباني ورئيس كوريا الجنوبيه ما
يجمع فوميو كيشيدا
اكثر مما يفرق بينهما جدول اعمال القمه
وتوقيتها والاوضاع الاقليميه والدوليه
والتحالفات القديمه والجديده امور كلها
تستدعي احياء علاقات متوتره من ارث مؤلم
مرتبطا بحقبه الاستعمار الياباني ابرز
ثمار هذه المحادثات التي طال انتظارها
قرروا وزاره التجاره اليابانيه رفع القيود
عن تصدير بعض المواد الكيميائيه للصول بعد
عقوبات فرضت عام 2019 سيعمل
على احياء اتفاقيه الاستخبارات العسكريه
المتوقفه بسبب تدهور العلاقات ما سمع خلال
المؤتمر الصحفي المشترك في نهايه القمه
اغلبه ان لم يكن كله رسائل مباشره للجاره
المزعجه كوريا الشماليه
تعزيز العلاقات بين اليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه في البيئه الاستراتيجيه الحاليه
امر ملح
التهديد الصاروخي الكوري الشمالي هو تهديد
كبير للسلام والاستقرار ينبغي ان تتعاون
كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان بشكل وثيق
وتتضامن للتعامل بحكمه مع هذه التهديدات
غير القانونيه عن التجربه الصاروخيه التي
سبقت القمه بالساعات وغيرها كان يعلق
الرئيسيون قبيل وصله طوكيو اطلقت
بيونغيونغ صاروخان باليسيا ضمن جدول اسبوع
مزدحم من التجارب الصاروخيه واستنادا
لهيئه الاركان الكوريه الجنوبيه
بعيد المدى وعابر للقارات اما مجلس
الوزراء الياباني فاوضح ان الصاروخ وصل
الى ارتفاع اكثر من سته الاف كيلو متر وهو
الاقصى له
تحذيراتو والتاثير المزدوج لرسائلها
الصاروخيه هو رد فعل كما تقول على
المناورات العسكريه المشتركه بين الولايات
المتحده والجاره الجنوبيه درع الحريه هو
اسم التدريبات التي بدات الثلاثاء وتستمر
عشره ايام تحاكي البيئه الامنيه المتغيره
لكوريا الشماليه بنظر بيونغ يونغ كل منوره
عسكريه في المنطقه هي تدريبات لغزوها ما
يزعج بيجين حاليا اكثر هو توجه اليابان
الى العسكره اعتبر المتحدث باسم وزاره
الدفاع الصينيه ذلك ادرارا بالسلام
والاستقرار
لعبت اليابان دورا فيما تسمى بالتهديدات
الخارجيه خلال السنوات الاخيره وخلق التوت
را في المنطقه ولديها نزعه خطيره للعوده
الى مسار العسكره
التاريخ هو العقبه التي تحول دون تطبيع
دائم بين طوكيو نتيجه التقارب الحالي
رهن تحديات كثيره معقده
[تصفيق]